hey guys welcome to vlog University this
week's homework assignment is going to
be make a video about your favorite
t-shirt and it just so happens that i'm
wearing my favorite t-shirt right now
got a little bit of mario a little
bowser got some luigi going on it's my
favorite be sure to submit your homework
assignment in the form of a video
response to this video right here make a
video about your favorite t-shirt why is
it your favorite t-shirt does your mom
want you to get rid of that favorite
t-shirt you've had it forever let's see
what you guys did for last week's
episode of fancy probably my favorite
video is by snail and it's a fancy
ballerina dog this is post-mortem
excellence yes I do believe this is
quite extraordinary
oh wait you want to see another fancy
dog here you go this is Ozzy Ozzy say
hello he's gonna sing for you today and
it's fancy clothes now fancy can mean so
many things to so many people but let me
tell you what there's nothing fancier
than an awesome violin player
for those of you that need some tips on
how to be fancy here's I serenity 10
with those very tips hi there and
welcome to a video how to be fancy there
in five steps to be dancing step one
dress fancy now if those tips weren't
enough here's some extra help from turno
times the fancy best individuals so the
first step to be in fancy is obviously
the leather jacket you gotta have it
it's a must-have if you don't got the
fancy leather jacket you ain't fancy
thank you guys so much for all of your
fancy episode submissions I thought they
were well fancy now don't forget because
for next week's vlog University it's
what's your favorite t-shirt I'm wearing
my favorite t-shirt so make your video
of your favorite t-shirt about your
favorite t-shirt and yeah out of is a
video response to this video I will see
you guys in the next vlog University
don't forget to do your homework be sure
to subscribe and check out the rest of
my wonderful YouTube channels here ok